The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm
really sick today.
And I hope I can make
it through this lecture
without disgracing myself.
But this is a favorite
topic of mine, too,
so maybe it will be OK.
So we're going to talk
about the helium atom, which
is really an amazing
thing because hydrogen--
it was possible to
solve it exactly.
All sorts of fantastic
things happened.
And it seemed like just a small
step from hydrogen to helium.
And nobody can take that step.
It's entirely approximate.
And you can do better and
better on the approximations,
but we'd like to have some
physical sense of what's
going on, and what are
the important terms,
and can we steal
things from hydrogen?
The answer is, yeah, we can.
And that was what last
lecture was mostly about.
The energies for hydrogen
are minus z squared hc times
the Rydberg over n squared.
And we have the ionization
energy from the nth level.
And so this actually
is the way we
make a link to this concept
of electronegativity
because the dominant
thing in electronegativity
is the ionization energy.
And this is the
ionization energy.
And when you put them
together and solve for n,
you get this arrangement hc
z squared times the Rydberg
over the ionization
energy, square root.
That's n, or the effective
principle quantum number.
And then we have all
of these formulas that
can be derived from
hydrogenic wave functions,
both for diagonal
expectation values
or off diagonal matrix elements.
They're all closed form.
And this is wonderful
because it then
enables you to use the formulas
that are obtained exactly
for hydrogenic wave functions.
And so if we know the dependence
of an electronic property on n
and l--
well, n is experimentally
determined--
distance real ionization.
l is determined from
angular momentum.
Then we can determine the
expected scaling of everything
on the quantum numbers.
And even if that's
wrong, it tells you
the qualitative effects when you
get to more complicated systems
in one electron atoms.
And this is really what
I meant by structure,
where everything is related
to basically one observation.
There is one other thing
that I didn't stress.
And it's another concept from
5.112., and that's shielding.
So suppose we have
a sodium atom.
Most of the electrons
are in a compact core.
The outer electron
sees a charge of 1,
even though the charge on
the nucleus is larger than 1.
And if you ask, well, suppose
we look at this in a region,
and we have an
electron inside of it,
the charge that
that electron sees
is the amount of electrons
inside the sphere defined
by this radius.
And so the z, we can
call it the z effective,
is a function of r.
And you have a different
function every o.
And so it's a way of
putting in more insight.
And I've made a lot of
mileage in my career
on these sorts of
scaling arguments.
OK, so helium-- the
notes are beautiful.
They're written by Troy.
And they're very long.
And they're very
correct and incisive.
And even if I weren't sick, I
couldn't cover all those notes.
So I'm going to make a rather
express trip through the notes.
And the critical thing
is we have two electrons.
And so we can't simply
solve the problem
by using hydrogenic functions,
although we would like to.
And the crucial
thing that is missing
is if we could ignore the
interactions between the two
electrons, which
are enormous, then
we would be using
hydrogenic functions,
and everything would be fine.
So we can't.
And we use what's called
the independent electron
approximation, where we're
still using hydrogenic orbitals
and energies, but
we're using those
to include the first
order perturbation
correction to the energies.
So there's a term, the
interelectron repulsion
that leads to this
extra correction energy.
And that's most
of the difference.
But then, we have
identical particles.
And when we have
identical particles,
the permutation of
those two particles
has to commute with
the Hamiltonian
because the Hamiltonian
only knows that we're
dealing with all the electrons.
It doesn't put names on
the individual electrons.
And so there's a
permutation symmetry
that has to be imposed.
And this is very subtle because
the permutation symmetry has
nothing to do with
the energy, but it has
to do with the energy states.
And so we'll explore that.
Now, since we're
going to be dealing
with more than one electron,
there's a lot of symbols
that we're going to
be carrying around.
And so there's a
useful thing called
the atomic units, which sets
most of the physical constants
to 1.
And that means all of the rubble
that you have to carry around
goes away.
And it's not a big
deal because if you
use all of the things in your
calculation in atomic units,
namely value 1 or something
like 1, then at the end,
you're going to get the
energy in atomic units.
And we know what that is
in conventional units.
So it's a risky thing
because you don't really
know what you're doing.
But at the end, you
can probably convert
your number, which is a pure
number, into an actual energy.
OK, so let me start
with the good news.
Well, maybe I should
leave this exposed.
The good news is we have
two particles for helium--
vector r, momentum, momentum
p vector for particle 1,
vector, momentum.
OK, so these are the actors.
And when do we have to
worry about commutation
or non-commutation?
Well, the answer
is the coordinates
associated with
different particles,
they contribute to the energy.
But there is no
problem of commutation.
The momenta don't also commute.
The coordinate for
particle 1 and the momentum
for particle 2, they commute.
The only things that doesn't
commute is r1x, p1x--
those kinds of things.
They're commutators
ih bar, and that
means there's some problems.
So most of the variables
are commuting variables,
but some are not.
And you have to deal with that.
OK.
We know that if we
have, as, for example,
in a three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator,
if we have a Hamiltonian
that doesn't commute--
if we can divide the
system up into parts, then
the Hamiltonian for each part
commutes with the Hamiltonian
for the other part,
which is part of this.
Then, you can write
the Hamiltonian
as a sum of individual
system Hamiltonians
that commute with each other,
the energies as the sum,
and the wave functions
as the product.
And so we like that.
And we'd like to be able to
build a picture for helium that
is like that.
And so if we write the
Hamiltonian for helium,
we have p squared for particle
1 over to me with p squared--
I don't know.
Le me see.
Let me organize better.
Minus zb squared over
4 pi epsilon 0 r1.
And then we have another term
like this for particle 2.
And we can call
this Hamiltonian 1.
I don't want to do that.
Hamiltonian 1, and
this Hamiltonian 2.
And these are hydrogen
atom Hamiltonians.
And we know
everything about them.
So it's a fantastic
way to build up
a basis set consisting of
energy, zero-order energies
and zero-order wave
functions, with which
we can calculate anything.
And so then we have
this one other term,
which plus e squared
over 4 pi epsilon 0
over 1 minus r minus r2 vectors.
That's the bad news.
This says we have a
Hamiltonian, where
we can't use the eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions
of the hydrogenic things unless
we do-- so we can say, well,
these give the first-order
energies for whatever state
we want.
But we can calculate matrix
elements of this term
in the basis set
associated with hydrogen.
And that's fine.
That's a perfectly
good way to calculate
the first-order
correction to the energy.
But what about this?
When we do perturbation
theory and calculate
the second-order
corrections to the energy,
what is that usually?
Maybe I didn't ask the
question clearly enough.
What do you have to do to get
these second-order energies
in an infinite
dimension problem?
I just gave it away.
Somebody has to have the
courage to say something here.
Remember, we have a sum of n not
equal to n from 0 to infinity.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That's it.
OK, I encouraged you.
So the way we could use this
basis set in a perturbation
theory format is to
calculate an infinite number
of off-diagonal matrix
elements of the hydrogenic wave
functions.
And that could yield
results, but it's not
the way it's done usually.
There's a variational
calculation
that you use to get the
better wave functions.
But we're not going
to do that here.
We're going to go
as far as we can
without actually addressing
what's wrong if we stop here.
OK, so this guy is h1,
the source of all trouble.
And how we deal with it
is there are three steps.
One is ignore it.
The other is use our
hydrogenic functions
to calculate matrix elements
of this and get an h1, an e1.
And the third step would
be to get the exact answer
by doing an infinitely
difficult calculation, OK?
All right.
So this is going to be a
notational voyage, which
is horrible.
Because we have many particles,
and particles have coordinates
and spins, we're going to
have an explosion of stuff,
even if we get rid of
the extraneous units.
But let's get rid of
And so atomic units--
we can choose any internally
consistent set of units
we want.
And in atomic units, we say that
the mass of the electron is 1.
The charge of the electron is 1.
The h bar is 1.
4 pi epsilon 0 is 1.
That's good.
A lot of stuff just going away.
OK, and the energy in
atomic units is not 1.
The energy in atomic
units is minus 2 times
the energy of the
hydrogenic 1s orbital.
And that comes out to
be 27.21 electron volts,
in more convenient units.
So you calculate a number, and
then you multiply it by this
to get the real energy.
OK, and the unit
of length is a0,
which is the radius of the
n equals 1 hydrogenic Bohr
orbital, or Bohr orbit.
And that's 0.529 angstroms,
with a lot more digits if you
need them, OK?
And the speed of light
is 137 in atomic units.
So everything that
you're going to need
is either 1 or something
that is related to--
OK, so you can do this,
and I don't like it
because it's so easy
in a big calculation
to get your units screwed up.
But it's certainly
great for lecturing
and perhaps for writing
computer programs.
OK, so let's start with a
non-interacting electron
approximation.
And in the notes, it's
represented by these letters.
I don't know
whether that this is
Troy notation or widely-adopted
in quantum chemical circles.
But it's easier to
write this than that.
And that just means we're
going to ignore this.
We just forget about it.
Now, we know that's stupid
because the electrons have
charge of 1.
And they repel each other.
And the nucleus has charge
of 2, in the case of helium.
And so we know that this
term is rather similar to h0.
And we can't expect to get very
far completely ignoring it.
But we can do it, and
we can do a calculation,
and we can find out
how well it works.
So first of all, it's
clear in the notes.
I'm just going to
skip to the answer.
So the energy for helium
in the 1s 1s orbital
or 1s 1s configuration--
when we're going to use this
word configuration, what
that means is the list of
orbitals that are occupied.
Now, we're listing
principal quantum number
and orbital angular momentum.
There is more stuff
which doesn't get listed,
and that leads to very
interesting stuff.
But if we have a list of
the orbitals are occupied.
That's called the
electronic configuration.
And I'm an electronic
spectroscopist,
so you can be sure this is
something I care a lot about.
So we can calculate this
in the hydrogenic basis.
And what you end up getting is--
where is it?
I'm sorry.
This is the experimental value.
The calculated value is--
see, I'm trying to
improve on my notes.
And in my present state,
I make a lot of mistakes.
So that is 108.8 electron volts.
So this is the energy of the 1s
1s state below the ionization
limit.
So that's what we predict.
Except this is not
the ionization limit.
This is helium 2+
plus 2 electrons.
Because we use the energy
to ionize both hydrogen
atoms, and so this is 108.8.
Now, you can measure
this experimentally.
You can do helium to
helium plus an electron,
and then helium plus going to
helium 2+ plus an electron.
And the observed value
is what I wrote before.
Observed is equal to minus
79.0 electrons volts.
Well, you might say,
well, that's pretty good.
It's the same
order of magnitude.
It's not even off
by a factor of 2.
But almost everybody in
this room is a chemist.
And this difference between
the calculated value
and the observed value
is 30 electron volts.
A chemical bond is
typically 5 electron volts.
So this is totally
ridiculous for chemistry.
We can't use it.
We don't even want
to think about it
because it's an
order of magnitude
away from what we need.
We improve on it by
including e1 of n,
which is related to h1, which
is that simple-looking thing
over there.
So the interelectron
repulsions can be dealt with,
not exactly, but by calculating
diagonal matrix elements
of the interelectron repulsion.
And that's what the independent
electron approximation is.
So that's all there is.
But now we bring in something
that we hadn't expected
would be a problem.
So we have this
mystical, or mythical,
or whatever operator--
p12 operating on some
function of r1 and r2.
And what it does is it
permutes the electrons.
We know that if
something is operating
on the names of
the electrons, it
has to commute with
the Hamiltonian.
So that means that
this operator has
to have eigenvalues if these
states are eigenfunctions
of the Hamiltonian.
And there are two
possible eigenvalues
because we know p12 squared
on psi is equal to plus psi.
So the only way you
can do that is having
the eigenvalue of the
permutation operator
be either plus 1 or minus 1.
And this is a
fundamental symmetry.
And I can't possibly tell
you where it comes from
or what I'm about to write
on the board comes from.
But so all half integer
spins correspond
to antisymmetry or belong
to the eigenvalue minus 1.
And they're called fermions.
And integer spins are
symmetric with permutations.
And so integer or symmetric,
and they're bosons.
So we have to write
wave functions which
are wave functions of
the electrons, which
are antisymmetric with
respect to the permutation
of every pair of electrons.
So helium, we only
have two electrons.
It's not so bad.
But when you think
about something
like carbon monoxide,
which I always think about,
or some other
molecule where there's
more than two electrons,
there's a God awful number
of permutations.
And you have to build them
all into the wave function.
And the normal feeling
when you hear that is,
oh, no, I can't possibly
imagine how to do that.
And if I could, there would be
a ridiculous number of integrals
that I would have to evaluate.
And it's true.
There are a ridiculous
number of integrals.
But there is a simple
algebra that enables you
how to deal with them.
And it involves using what is
called Slater determinantal
wave functions.
And I'll talk about that.
Slater was an MIT professor.
He wrote a lot of books.
But the thing-- integer.
Oh, they'res sort of a t.
But the most
important thing he did
was to develop
this way of dealing
with an antisymmetric
electronic wave functions.
So the next thing we
have to do is discover
how do we build symmetric wave
functions for the simplest
possible case where
there's two electrons?
And already, we discover
some surprising consequences
for this.
And so I'm going
to go through this,
but I'm going to
skip a lot of steps
because it's so clearly
written in the notes
and because we don't
really have time
to deal with 15 pages
of single-spaced notes.
And I'm not sufficiently at my
best to get through maybe 12.
And you don't want that, anyway.
OK, so let us see
what happens here.
And so let's get to work.
Suppose we have an electronic
state 1s alpha spin.
We know alpha is
ms equals plus 1/2.
And beta is ms equals minus 1/2.
So this is the
spatial coordinate.
This is the spin coordinate.
And, OK, so here is a simple
product of two wave functions.
And we know what they are.
And so if we apply p12 to this,
we get psi 1s alpha r2 sigma
2 1s beta r1 sigma 1.
We don't even know what
this is relative to that.
So symbolically, these are
two unrelated quantities.
So weird, but they
are eigenfunctions
of the zero-order Hamiltonian.
So we can take a linear
combination of eigenfunctions
that belong to the
same eigenvalue,
and it's still the same energy.
So we do that.
And so what we can do is write
a combination of this function
and that function.
And if we do that, so now
we can have psi 1s 2s.
And what we get is 1 over
the square root over 2
for normalization.
And we have psi 1s alpha r1
sigma 1 minus psi 1s beta
r1 r2 sigma 2.
And this, in fact,
is anti-asymmetric.
If you apply the permutation
operator to this,
it is an antisymmetric function.
So this does the job.
Now, since the Hamiltonian
doesn't depend on spin,
the energy of this state
and the energy of that state
are the same.
They are hydrogenic.
And so using this wave
function rather than
the individual
non-symmetrized functions
doesn't change the energies.
So are we wasting our time?
AUDIENCE: I think you
didn't [INAUDIBLE]..
This should be the product
of 1s alpha 1s beta.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: So the [INAUDIBLE]
must be [FINGER SNAPPING]
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: Minus the other one.
PROFESSOR: I just want
to see what I wrote here.
So yeah, what I wrote is wrong.
1s alpha, and we'll
just put 1 in here.
1s beta 2 minus 1s
alpha 2 1s beta 1.
OK, this is what I
should have written.
And this is, in
fact, antisymmetric.
Thank you.
I wrote what's in my
notes, which is wrong.
And I didn't realize I had done
that because I knew the answer.
All right.
OK, so we can use
this kind of function.
It's legal because
it's an eigenfunction
of the permutation operator
with negative symmetry, which
we're told that's what we
have to use for electrons.
I can't tell you
where it comes from,
although it came from Pauli.
And the exclusion
principle really
is this, rather than
what you have memorized.
Its consequence is
that you can only
put one electron in an orbital.
But this is the exclusion
principle, and it is Pauli.
OK, so now we know what to do.
And we can calculate
the matrix elements.
psi 1s alpha go in 1s beta.
This is the antisymmetrized
product of two electrons.
Matrix element 1
for Hamiltonian 1
plus 1 over r1 minus r2
psi 1s alpha 1s beta.
Though this is a perfectly
legitimate thing to calculate
and we know how to do it, or
McQuarrie knows how to do it.
And you don't
really need to worry
about doing these
integrals because this
is at such a low-level
approximation,
it does nothing for
you except teach you
how to approach these problems.
But we can still
do these integrals.
And it's useful.
And so what do you get?
Well, you get minus
4y because these
are hydrogenic with
a nucleus of plus 2.
And in the atomic
units, the energy
of a hydrogen atom charge
of 1 is 1/2, not 1.
And these go as z squared, so
we get 4 over 2 plus 4 over 2.
So we get this minus
4 or you get minus--
yes.
And then we get something else.
And that's this integral
that we don't like,
which is integral of 1s
alpha 1s beta squared
over r1 minus r2 dr1 dr2.
So we can do this integral,
or Mr. McQuarrie and many
of his predecessors can do that
integral, and you get a result.
And this integral turns
out to be 5z over 8.
And converting that into
units, and that's 5/4 au.
And that's-- why is that?
That doesn't seem right.
Anyway, it's 34 electron volts
or minus 34 electron-- plus.
Plus 34 electron volts--
so the interelectronic repulsion
for hydrogenic orbitals
on the same nucleus
is 34 electron volts.
It's a big number.
And so we can correct our the
calculated versus observed
energy.
And instead of having--
well, the experimental
value is 79.
And now, the calculated value
is minus 74.8 electron volts.
So this is marginally
relevant to chemistry
because the error is about
the typical bond energy.
And so we can do
stuff with this.
We know that it's
not accurate enough
to do anything quantitative.
But you can use it for
qualitative arguments.
And we can do much
better than this
using what's going to be called
the variational principle,
which is coming.
OK, so now, we're going to be
dealing with a problem that has
lots of symbols and equations.
And it's best to start using
notation called stick diagrams
because it's completely
transparent what they mean.
And so it's a shortcut for
writing the correct equations.
So we have for the ground
state of hydrogen--
I'm sorry.
We want to talk about excited
states because 1s with 1s
doesn't have enough complexity
to attract our attention.
And when we deal with
excited states, 1s and 2s,
we discover something
important that's new.
And it's the last
thing we really
need in order to understand
electronic structure
or how the electronic states
that arise from a configuration
are distinguished.
And so we have for the
1s 2s configuration,
there are four ways of writing
this in stick diagrams.
So we have 1s 2s, and we can
have spins up, alpha alpha.
And we can have 2s 1s.
We can have spins up and down.
2s 1s, and spins down and up.
And 2s 1s spins down.
So it's much easier
to write these things
because they have an equation
to associate with them,
and you can play
with these symbols.
So the first thing you
notice is this symbol
can be written as an
antisymmetrized product.
And so this symbol--
we just take the alpha alpha.
And so let me just write it out.
1 over square root of 2 times
1s r1 2s r2 minus psi 1s r2
psi 2s r1.
And then times a
spin part, alpha--
and we can just
abbreviate the 1--
and alpha.
OK, so we have factored
the wave function
to a spatial part
and a spin part.
Now, I'll make an
outrageous statement.
Doesn't matter how
many electrons.
You'll always be
able to factor it
into a spatial part
and a spin part.
Now, what is necessary
is always this function
has to be antisymmetric.
And in this case,
it's the spatial part
that's antisymmetric and the
spin part that's symmetric.
Now, when we try to do
these two stick diagrams.
we cannot write a correct
equation for this guy.
We have to do both of them.
We have to combine the two.
And that will give us a
separated spin part and spatial
part.
And it's antisymmetric.
You can't make in an asymmetric
function of this just switching
the coordinates.
And what you find
when you do this
is going to be that
we get functions
which look like alpha beta
plus or minus beta alpha.
OK, so spin 1 alpha spin
2 beta plus or minus
spin 1 beta spin 2 alpha.
And it turns out that there are
three spin functions that we
get, which are symmetric.
And all three of
these are associated
with this antisymmetric
spatial function.
They have the same energy.
And since they're three of
them, we call them a triplet.
And since we're
talking about spins,
this triplet corresponds
to s equals 1.
You use s equals 1 and creation
and annihilation operators
or raising and
lowering operators
to show that these are, in fact,
the three eigenstates of s sub
z.
So we call it a triplet
because they're three of them.
And it also corresponds
to s equals 1.
And there's one, alpha
beta minus beta alpha,
which is antisymmetric
and is associated
with a different spatial
function, which is symmetric.
And it has to have
a different energy
because the Hamiltonian operates
on the spatial part and not
on the spin part.
So antisymmetry has
forced you to have
two different spatial
wave functions,
and that guarantees
that these guys
will have different energies.
And since there's only one of
them, we call it a singlet,
and it corresponds
to s equals 0.
So now, we want to know,
which is higher in energy,
the singlet or the triplet?
And how much higher?
And so, again, we take
the wave functions
that are correct as far as
permutation is concerned,
but only approximate as far
as using hydrogenic functions,
and we evaluate the relevant
terms in the Hamiltonian.
OK, so we can forget
about the spin parts now.
We know we're going to have
two different spatial wave
functions.
And we're going to want
to calculate-- yes?
AUDIENCE: For the top
state, [INAUDIBLE]
both spins [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That should be?
AUDIENCE: Would that
also be s equals 0?
PROFESSOR: I can't hear.
I understand the last word.
AUDIENCE: With the statement,
both spin be also s equals 0?
PROFESSOR: No.
Both spins up.
The vector sum of
1/2 and 1/2 is 1.
And so the total spin
is going to be 1.
And so we have 3--
I mean, if we're
applying s minus--
suppose we start with--
AUDIENCE: I meant that the top
spin [INAUDIBLE] both spins.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
I can't hear properly.
AUDIENCE: The topmost state
with both spins on it?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Would that have
s equals 0 or s equals 1?
PROFESSOR: It has s equals 1.
OK.
And now, I don't want to go
into the angular momentum matrix
element.
That would be the last
thing in this lecture.
So yes, the projection
quantum numbers
are not uniquely associated
with the total spin.
But if you have alpha alpha, you
can show that it's s equals 1.
And alpha beta plus
beta alpha is 1.
And beta beta is 1.
But alpha beta minus
beta alpha is spin 0.
You can do that using creation
and annihilation operators.
It's clear, OK?
So you have to take
it on faith until you
prove what I've just said.
And it takes about two minutes.
OK, so we can evaluate
the integrals.
And something very
beautiful occurs.
And it's done very, very
clearly in the notes.
And it would take me more time
than we have left to do it,
and I didn't plan
on doing it anyway.
So we get the energies for the
singlet and triplet states,
which are E 1s plus E 2s.
Now, remember, these are
for a 1s orbital on helium,
so it's going to be
four times the energy
of the 1s orbital on hydrogen.
But we know what they are.
Plus what we call J 1s2s
plus or minus K 1s2s.
So this is clear.
And the integral
associated with this
is taking the square
of the wave function.
And basically, we're
evaluating the interaction
between an electron 1 in the
1s orbital and electron 2
in the 2s orbital.
So that's a perfectly
doable thing.
It's a classical quantity.
We have two charged
distributions,
and we're calculating
the energy interaction
between two electrons in these
two charged distributions.
So this is called
the Coulomb integral.
And that is an entirely
classical quantity.
And this is called
the exchange integral.
And the reason we call it
an exchange integral is,
basically, we're
switching the electrons
between the two orbitals.
And this is something which is
entirely quantum mechanical.
It comes about because of
the permutation symmetry
that's required for fermions.
And so this is the surprise.
And it also depends
on whether you
have a symmetric,
or an antisymmetric,
or a single, or a triplet.
And so you end up
getting an energy level
diagram for the state of
a configuration, which
looks like this.
So we start out with E 0 1s2s.
And then we allow the charged
distributions to interact.
And the electrons are
going to repel each other.
It's a positive energy.
And so this is E 0 plus J. And
then, we include the exchange
interaction.
And so this is
the difference 2K.
And this is E0 plus J plus K.
And this is E0 plus J minus K.
And this is the triplet state.
And this is a singlet.
And for helium, we
call the singlet state
singlet s because total
angular momentum is 0.
And spin, it has 0.
And the triplet we
call a triplet s.
Now, if we did 1s 2p, we would
get singlet and triplet p
states.
But the important
thing is, how big is K?
And remember, K is
an approximation.
It's a real quantity, but
for hydrogenic orbitals,
it's going to be incorrect.
And so 2K 12 is
2.4 electron volts.
And that's a perfectly
doable calculation
because you're dealing
with simple functions.
And you can do this integral.
And you can actually
do it in closed form.
But it's 2.4 electron volts.
And experiment, it's 0.8.
And this tells you
something really important.
The repulsion between
two electrons,
when you have the
correct wave function,
is less than it would be if
you're using the wrong wave
functions.
And basically, whenever you do
anything using the wrong wave
functions, your energy
levels are too large
or the energy differences
are too large.
And in this case, the electrons.
And when you solve the
exact Schrodinger equation,
the electrons know about how to
absorb it to avoid each other.
It's called correlation energy.
And this is what makes all the
calculations hard because there
is no closed form analytic
expression for the correlation
energy.
And the way you optimize
the correlation energy
is throwing a huge basis
set at the problem.
And this is why it takes a long.
And you never know that you've
converged until you fill
in another million functions.
OK, but so there
are several lessons.
And that is we have something
that's completely classical,
and we understand what it is.
And then, we have
this extra thing
that is a consequence of
the permutation symmetry.
And so this extra thing
we calculated too big.
But it says that
if we have states
that belong to the same
electronic configuration--
in other words, if we specify
the orbitals that are occupied,
there's going to be more
than one electronic state.
And so configurations split
into many different electronic
states.
And we know the machinery
that enables us to calculate
their relative energies.
And some of it is
simple Coulomb's law.
something that's
caused by the required
permutation symmetry.
So I'm over time.
But I can't believe
that I got to this point
because I delivered everything
that was really important.
When we have more than two
electrons, everything I've said
is true, it's just
more complicated.
And we have to evaluate
matrix elements
between determinantal
wave functions, which
looks like, if you
have n electrons,
there's n factorial
terms in a determinate.
And we have n factor l
squared matrix elements.
And you don't want to do that.
But there turns out to
be a simple algebra that
makes it all pop out, almost
with the same level of effort
as this.
And so we'll talk about
many electron atoms,
and then we'll go
on to molecules
after the many
electron atoms lecture.
OK.